[Musica]
sapete più o meno quando mi ricordo di
essere tarantino quando quando mi
arrabbio quando mi vengono i cinque
minuti al di là del fatto che negli
ultimi come diceva prima dieci anni ho
cambiato otto città ogni volta che mi
arrabbio ogni volta che minchia nano i
cinque minuti improvvisamente diventa
tarantino per cui spero di non
arrabbiarmi da qui fino alla fine dello
special cosa ho fatto negli ultimi dieci
anni
anzi forse 15 ho studiato lavorato e
creato start up sfruttandolo artificial
intelligence and machine learning con un
solo scopo quello di aiutare le persone
a ridurre il numero di alternative a
fare le scelte giuste e sfruttando
appunto gli algoritmi questo l'ho fatto
prima da lavoratori a torino poi l'ho
fatta da ricercatore a new york quello
fatto creando la mia prima start up sul
social sui social network in california
e adesso lo faccio cercando di aiutare
le imprese che hanno grossi impianti
produttivi ad ottimizzare i processi
sfruttando i dati questo che significa
significa che molto spesso utilizzare i
dati utilizzare l'attività di
intelligence significa vedere i dati del
passato conoscere lo storico il mio
professione a new york ha sempre mi
diceva quasi sempre guarda è
importantissimo che tu sappia gestire le
informazioni dello storico perché a dare
algoritmi predittivi però ricordati
sempre una cosa nel momento in cui tu
crei un algoritmo predittivo a quel
punto sta guidando una macchina solo
usando lo specchietto retrovisore alla
prima curva che non è previsto te ne vai
addosso un'altra cosa che mi diceva
tantissimo e che ripeteva spesso ho poi
scoperto che in realtà la diceva ancora
ancor prima che fosse inventata da
artificial intelligence e la diceva da
diceva albert einstein albert einstein
diceva in inglese
artificial intelligence and snow match
di omar stupidity gli algoritmi alla
fine le fanno sempre le persone per cui
se l'algoritmo è fatto da una persona
stupida molto probabilmente l'algoritmo
lavorera in maniera stupida
però qual è la cosa più triste di tutti
gli alla fine per quanto possiamo
cercare di usare gli algoritmi nella
vita reale ci sono delle informazioni
che non possiamo inserire all'interno
dell'algoritmo per esempio le emozioni
ed è per questo che ci tengo
particolarmente a finire diciamo questa
questa sessione didattica sull'artigiano
intelligence e passare visto che sono
taranto sono cresciuto alla salinella a
raccontarvi come un algoritmo funziona
perlomeno come funzionato nella mia
testa nel momento in cui sono stato
invitato qui a taranto a partecipare non
vi nascondo che abbiamo di fronte due
scelte quindi avevo la scelta di non
venire la scelta di divenire provarci ho
deciso di farlo però avevo in fondo al
cuore qualcosa che mi diceva guarda è
difficile in questo contesto io poi sono
sparito da taranto per anni qui avevano
una certa sensazione un certo senso di
colpa che devo dire quest'oggi è stato
rimosso perché io cerco sempre di fare
qualcosa per taranto nel mio piccolo e
tre anni fa ha lanciato con degli amici
con degli amici di taranto un crowd
funding perché la ruffa bla bla città
vecchia
pensate che quando sono venuto qui
quindi sono venuto qui nello del taranto
ero convinto che anche se eravamo
riusciti a raccogliere 15mila euro
perché arifa blob pensavo che non si
fosse fatto niente in realtà oggi ha
scoperto che la città vecchia hanno
consegnato tre stampanti 3d e quindi
vuol dire che ci vuole tempo ma taranto
le cose possono possono accadere qui ci
vuole un bell'applauso prestampati
presenti
quindi ok ho deciso di venire
dopodiché ha fatto ho fatto la cosa più
più più intelligente che potessi fare
sono andato su whatsapp e ho chiesto a
tutti gli amici miei spazi nel pianeta
di taranto quali argomenti dovrei
trattare il primo il più simpatico mi ha
risposto subito e mi ha detto il tema è
l'alternativa cosimo sito un'alternativa
non era alternativo 18 anni figuriamoci
adesso non è il casco li alternativo più
cosa ma si sapeva
poi a un certo punto è venuto fuori il
tema il tema per cui ormai noi siamo
famosi in tutto il pianeta
e visto che se ne discuteva non riuscivo
a capire io con due lauree una tesi di
dottorato
non riesco ancora a capire lo ha detto
questo tema che avete capito benissimo
qual è non lo tratterò mai per cui ho
fatto una cosa che è quando si
sviluppano algoritmi si fa spessissimo
che è una cosa che fate anche nella vita
decidete cosa non volete fare cosa
volete dire per cui una volta che
scremate le vie d'uscita dell'algoritmo
dell'albero decisionale vi rimangono
quelle positive per cui ho deciso di non
parlare di quella cosa lì e oltre il mar
piccolo di non citare la marina di non
citare la salinella della sede nato
cresciuto e pasciuto di non c'entrare
era erasmo iacovone dove ho passato
tutte le domeniche della mia infanzia di
non citare la birra raffo
a meno che non c'è qualche manager che è
pronto a gad a quel punto l'algoritmo
cambia completamente
e soprattutto deciso di non parlare in
dialetto perché non voglio entrare in
quei cliché
subito dopo il mio algoritmo nella mia
testa ha detto va bene fai di nuovo
quello che è importante fare per vedere
cosa è successo nel passato apre
youtube.com brunori sas l'anno scorso
plano di sassa arriva qui simpaticissimo
tiene il palco che l'empatia niente
slide modestamente almeno quello copiato
e soprattutto porta il pianoforte hanno
visto liso e carlino nostra se lo posso
fare
in ogni caso breweries asse ha fatto una
cosa molto interessante ha parlato di se
stesso e questo è quello che voglio fare
perché taranto fondamentalmente mi ha
dato è stata una grande palestra di vita
in città in luoghi come questi dove le
risorse sono poche
bisogna essere veloci bisogna essere
svegli
bisogna essere capaci di trovare sempre
l'alternativa giusta
molto spesso anche velocemente per
esempio quando ero piccolo io sono
tifoso della juventus ma non avevo da
regalare un bellissimo pallone della
juventus veniva dal negozio compriamo
vogliamo comprare il parole al vento ma
non c'era ovviamente che all'epoca già
c'erano troppi juventini in giro prende
un bellissimo pallone della roma bianco
di cuoio con un bel lupacchiotto
disegnato sopra lo porto a casa e
probabilmente per due mesi non è mai
usato perché perché avevo paura quando
lo appoggiamo a terra sul cemento si
sarebbe devastato
dopo due mesi mi convinco prendo il
pallone dopo già terra forse un minuto
arriva uno delle case popolari che
voleva rubare prende col corpo ma
velocissimo che fatturano scena youtube
che altrimenti verrebbero omologato
qualche record però ho scelto
velocemente quella situazione
sempre rimanendo nell'ambito calcistico
taranto mi ha insegnato anche a trovare
soluzioni alternative a scegliere il
male minore
quante volte avete fatto quel tiro
fantastico che andava sopra la traversa
immaginare che avevate immaginato che
c'erano perché c'erano due pietre a
terra e quindi in quel momento tutti
dicevano ai gol e gol
potrei metri discussione non arriva
nessuno che faceva questo simbolo questo
gesto ma arrivava sempre quello che
diceva o collo o gol rigore bravissimi o
palloni e quindi immaginate abbiamo
creato un'alternativa fantasiosa a quel
punto due sceglie wilma nomina quale si
deve ritirare il rigore perché la bello
tirare il rigore
taranto non è che mi ha anche insegnato
a gestire le persone in maniera diversa
rispetto alle situazioni appena
patentato a san vito faccio elettro
marcia a un certo punto con la mia
vecchia punto bob da una botta dietro da
dietro sente una voce abbastanza
ancestrale dire 23 a bastoni qua sarà
difficile non dire non usare non usare
non usare il dialetto
io onestamente non l'avevo mai sentito
il termine tria bastoni e ho chiesto che
ho chiesto aiuto a casa e il mio nonno
mi ha detto guarda è mai visto il 3
bastone quanto è brutto e quindi è
un'offesa
io in quel momento io in quel momento ho
pensato tra me e me va bene agisco bello
caliente tarantino e stavo per dire quei
succo di frutta guzzetta incartata cobb
difficilissimo ma ce l'ho fatta
mancano cinque minuti ancora non ho
parlato in dialetto però in quel momento
ho capito se uno mi usa un termine del
genere con questo gergo forse è meglio
uscire la mano a chiedere scusa e
partire taranto poche risorse
vent'anni fa trent'anni fa avevamo un
obiettivo unico quando finiva la scuola
andare a prendere il pullman intel e
magna grecia per andrea gandoli a quel
punto passava la circolare nera la
circolare rossa tre controllori il 14
sbarrato super pieno lo potevi prendere
poi improvvisamente arrivava un pullman
dove c'era scritto saturo era una specie
di miraggio perché tu dicevi caspita
posso prendere per pullman el vado
dritto senza passare per talsano lama e
altri posti per ora sempre troppo pieno
io onestamente adesso non ho un ricordo
esatto di che tipo di informazioni
utilizzavo di che algoritmo mi frullava
nella testa procedere l'obiettivo
arrivare a mare e nonostante tutto ci
sono sempre riuscito ad arrivare
non c'era un anno a gps né waits né
altro
questo cosa significa che noi tutti i
giorni facciamo siamo abituati a gestire
situazioni complesse andò e spesso come
si diceva prima avere tante alternative
genera ansia nelle coscienze dicono che
less is more
cioè se io nel marketing cento parametri
per scegliere un prodotto
paradossalmente mi trovo in una
situazione di ansia ma realtà c'è una
cosa molto peggiore di avere un sacco di
alternative e spesso capita capita a
tutti c'è sentirsi di non avere nessuna
alternativa
ok ed è per questo che spero di
riuscirci
ho portato virtualmente il mio sachs
perché in realtà non è importante
l'algoritmo che utilizzate nel momento
in cui
prendete la decisione ma la cosa
importante è arrivare con la giusta
serenità per prendere la decisione
giusta o sbagliata che sia per cui il
sax per me rappresenta l'alternativa non
mi darà da mangiare non mi permetterà di
pesce dei miei figli non mi permetterà
di crescere muto ma ogni volta che
qualcuno mi mette nelle condizioni di
disagio
oppure non sono in grado di decidere mi
costruisco penso la mia alternativa e
decido
l'alternativa è prendere il sax
andarmene in giro per l'italia a suonare
per le metropolitane e campare sereno
per cui quello che vi chiedo io e rifare
sempre lo sforzo di non farvi mai
trovare senza un'alternativa senza senza
il vostro sax senza la vostra scarpetta
d'arancia senza la vostra il vostro
cacciavite senza nostra canna da pesca
senza le vostre scarpe da tennis perché
purtroppo succederà ancora una cosa
peggiore di non avere alternative che
arriverà un fesso qualsiasi e vi dirà
cose mi dispiace ma non hai nessuna
alternativa
e a quel punto voi lo guarda in faccia
cosa giusta aplomb tarantina li direte
voi e su credo solo ma vide centrerà e
propria
[Applauso]
bene così